[Musique]
le bol d'or au
genou le reçoit les enfants nounours et
bien gai ce soir vieux bol patron je
suis content de retrouver mes amis m'ont
le schale
europe au propofol
[Musique]
c'est une véritable blanchisserie 7
relate je vais rester longtemps comme ça
je d'aider damas elle me gratte le nez
ses plaies bonsoir ou mais c'est tout
mouillé partage t'inquiète pas nous vous
félicite elle est magnifique cette laine
oulala excuses et moins chère d'odeda je
ne vous avais pas reconnu doria jeanny
vous vous tricoter un pull over pour
l'hiver non je rends service
mais je commence à trouver que les
plaisanteries les plus courtes sont les
meilleures ne voyez d'abord le dit jean
ce de me débarrasse hirscher nonos
voulons tu t'attends voulons tueur
à papeete leur confie la halle aux ours
[Musique]
ouf je commence à être chargé des mois
mais que fais tu avec je bois mais des
faits mais je commence à transpirer mois
débarrasser mois les enfants cornichons
minutes nous jettent à cette chaussée
[ __ ]
une minute une minute mais j'ai tout
fait moi patience et longueur de temps
font plus que force et
patience je veux la pause par terre
cette laine
au commun des quotas quel travail tu va
sécher
[Musique]
oui quelle belle lessive
ouf le travail est la santé frères
nounours et le sommeil aussi
allons on lit les travailleurs
[Musique]
de nuit petite pépite à beaune nuits le
zoo aux
animaux
[Musique]
au
menu mais juliette un
émoi alors
venir ou de da a quand même
[Musique]
dépêche-toi nounours nous sommes en
retard nous avons encore beaucoup
d'autres enfants à aller voir pourvu
qu'il n'ait pas fait la lessive bord tu
es fatigué mon patron le travail c'est
la santé
je suis en pleine forme route bonnier
des enfants allez vite vous coucher
n'oubliez pas de faire votre toilette et
de gens vous l'a vu le don embrasser
bien fort vos parents avez fait pour
[Musique]
oh
m
en